moi j'ai envie de dire que
vous avez l'impression vous dit que les
femmes sont un peu dégradée et c'est
l'image de la femme qu on dégrade à
travers émission télé réalité ou des
influenceurs moi ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire c'est que c'est faux pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui les candidates et
khalid et les stars des candidats des
stars d'été réalité ce sont des femmes
déjà moi je suis la preuve vivante je
suis une femme j'anime attribue une
émission de télé réalité on s'impose et
dans une émission télé réalité on
représente la jeunesse et pourquoi
pourquoi images emmagasinées votre auto
de chirurgie esthétique mais moi j'ai 40
ans déjà
mais mais les femmes justement télé
représente la jeunesse c'est à dire que
vous avez toutes sortes de femmes et
pour ceux qui suivent la téléralité
vraiment au lieu des 11 femmes au lait
les stigmates si vous allez pouvoir voir
que vous avez d'aidé de magna magali et
se ressemblent tout arrêter non c'est
pas vrai corps et iv vous avez des
personnes comme 12 et pas comme ilona
raison camilla des personnes parfait des
personnes refaite on représente il
représente la jeunesse et ça c'est la
vérité et je vous invite à regarder les
émissions mathieu bah oui pardon mais
madame tussaud's avait un très bon
discours méchante qu'il a trente ans en
arrière aujourd'hui quand bien même
moquée par ton c h oeur esthétique ces
jeunes filles veulent en faire on parle
plus de lister ou en coupe et la peau
comme il ya 30 ans c'est la médecine
marion savane esthétique et si on peut
donner l'occasion à des gamines après 16
ans complexe comptera moyens je suis
désolé
sans rigoler arrête de se faire refaire
les lèvres à 16 ans c'est n'importe quoi
je suis désolé le monde avance la mise
en série à lazio joue
dangereux tu dangereux dans ses comptes
une dernière chose si je peux me
permettre quand on met juste pour réunir
sur pourquoi ces dangereuses comme
jean-louis vous êtes en train de faire
penser à nos jeunes que s'il ne s'aiment
pas tels qu'ils sont peuvent avoir
recours à la chirurgie esthétique c'est
ça c'est mal bah oui c'est moche
c'est en 18 ans chipé à 17 ans 18 ans et
on voit déjà et vous allez où mais dans
le même temps mais c'est n'importe quoi
on voit des trucs incroyables
on voit des choses je vois des gens ils
ont changé prison padrines ce sont des
trucs et cyril s'est pas dit fait
n'importe quoi et en
2014 à savoir ce que tu racontes là
c'est que tu dit en gros s'il ne s'en
sentent pas bien dans leur peau mais qui
ne l'est qui fait qu'ils ne se sentent
pas bien dans leur peau c'est pas je ne
suis pas bien ex nihilo parce que ça
fait 10 ans 15 ans que je vis avec lui
les oreilles décollées ou en équipe team
gym contrarie c'est parce que je regarde
cette émission que tout à coup je me dis
tiens je ne ressemble pas et donc tiens
je ne me sens pas malheureusement
c'est la première chose est la seconde
chose c'est que dans des émissions aussi
il ya un rapport entre les hommes et les
femmes quoi qu'en dise magali que j'aime
beaucoup au demeurant mais tu peux pas
nier magali qu'en revanche on voit très
souvent des garçons par les très très
mal à des jeunes femmes même si elles
ont du répondant peu importe ça induit
une idée d'un rapport entre les hommes
et les femmes c'est un rapport tout le
temps conflictuelle ses filiales rapport
aux 12,8 on se parle mal on s'insulte
alors et donc non cet établissement
valérie juste moi je vais donner leurs
marges dans la taille puisque votre fils
fait de la télé réalité - will avait dit
quoi en tant que père moi je moi je lui
ai dit écoute je fais ce que tu veux
honnêtement ça ma part à vis maintenant
je trouve que c'est un nouveau métier et
tout n'est pas à jeter à la poubelle
après moi je vous rejoint pas forcément
c'est que le fait que les jeunes et des
modèles esthétiques c'est ça fait des
années qu'ils avaient des dizaines
d'années qu'on va avancer les
top-modèles abobo non c'est pas très
grave en revanche moi j'ai là où je vous
rejoins c'est comme à ma belle fille me
demande pour pour ses 18 ans une paire
de seins là je me dis merde ah oui ils
ont raison mais je vous dis je vais
donner votre nom
à vivre l'association que c'est un vrai
problème et c'est vrai et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui la téléréalité par rapport à
ce que j'ai pu présenter dans le passé
effectivement ça se gâte oui c'est ça ce
que les un peu moins c'était
moi je vous le dit madame ministre il ya
une façon très très très simple de
régler les problèmes si effectivement le
guen on considère que c'est un danger
pour la jeunesse nous c'était notre
hantise faut magnifier ou non la valeur
c'était notre hantise quand on sait que
la storim était à moins de 12 et ils
passeront à 22 heures il y aura plus
programmer ce n'était pas
plein gay toute une industrie où on est
d'accord il a vérité est là je lâche le
dit
géraldine maillet non mais c'est vrai
c'est grave de dire ça moi j'ai toujours
dit que je déteste et ses parents comme
quoi quand je l'aï regardé et je
condamne pas du tout les gens qui
veulent participer à ces programmes
parce que je pense que c'est aussi
normal quand on est jeune on a envie de
notoriété d'argent et voilà je peux très
bien comprendre mais en revanche excusez
moi mais depuis plusieurs mois on reçoit
ici c'est vrai nom de faits divers
concernant la téléralité alors c'est le
truc vaudou est adroit
céleri le racket la drogue leur diamant
les les histoires et les réseaux sociaux
ça c'est pas les mérites et tu plaisante
avec andy dans les six mois qui l'a
annoncé sur les réseaux que les gens
viennent ici pour en parler il s'est
depuis dit oui mais ce sont des
candidats issus des vérités mais les
résidents bien mais ils sont
déçus de la télé réalité une réalité
valeur donne une plate forme qu'il
n'aurait pas eue s'il n'était pas passé
par là c'est le rôle d' influence dont
on parlait tout à l'heure qui est
important vous ne pouvez pas lorsque
vous avez de l' influence sur une
jeunesse qui est en pleine construction
faire n'importe quoi et dire n'importe
quoi pardonnez moi et ça n'est pas une
censure absolument pas le nous avons
dans notre pays cette possibilité de
créer la liberté créé est extrêmement
importante je dis juste qu'il faut être
conscient de l'impact que vous avez sur
la société s'est opposé nasa même les
enfants ce qui est bien c'est pas à
l'état mais je ne suis pas d'accord
l'accord initial non pas dans les ailes
sont pas dans les standards d'elana
teleread je suis pas d'accord avec vous
mathieu q j'aimerais d'accord avec vous
c'est pas aux parents et les parents
bien sûr ils ont enroulé mais vous
pouvez pas aussi serré
passé sur les réseaux sociaux et sur et
sur des sur des sources d émission de
télé comprenez que sont des exemples
alors après si l'on se dire qu'il permet
de mettre tout le temps derrière eux ils
doivent regarder ce qui est bien c'est
pas possible aujourd'hui tu peux pas
aujourd'hui c'est impossible tu peux pas
enlever les écrans
aux ados c'est impossible de leur
enlever les écrans voilà donc je dis
qu'aujourd'hui là tu te trompe de combat
il faut que le gouvernement agisse et en
séries c'est la quadrature du cercle pas
ce que vous dites à la fois il faut
faire quelque chose et en même temps on
peut pas vraiment faire quelque chose
parce que si on fait quelque chose de
programmes ne fonctionne non pas du tout
menacé producteur exécutif pour moi donc
pour le producteur qui est sur le
terrain d'accord qui doit réguler tout
ça qui doit elle sur les montages parce
qu'il ya des trucs contre contre ces des
émissions qui sont pas en direct il ya
plein de trucs qu'on pourrait couper
mais sa
maladie mais ça veut dire quoi c'est à
dire que pour faire de l'audience
forcément aux gardes décès qu'en afrique
qui sont limite donc fort du gaz bah
voilà exactement donc il faut faire
réfléchir un peu moins de bugs je vous
dire quand un jour vous allez dire aux
producteurs et jours des gens j'en fais
partie pauline quand vous allez dire aux
producteurs un moment où vous baissez le
curseur ou bien on va complètement
arrêtés on va vous trouver à 22h est ce
que je veux d aller voir si ça va bouger
s'il ne va pas bouger rapidement
joli mais c'est sûr qu'après je vous dis
c'est pas pour et moi je pense que ça
doit rester à 18h 19h bien sûr mais
normal on descend du bus heureux on va
pas le mettre 10 à 22 heures c'est vrai
mais il faut juste un moment et c'est le
curé c'est un peu le curseur et se dire
voilà aujourd'hui on peut pas tout
laisser passer et on en valeur on sait
comment ça se passe les les productions
de téléralité matthieu delormeau
mauvaise foi syrie c'est que dans ces
cas là alors enlevons aussi toutes les
filles qui font 30 kg qui font la une
des magazines parce que ça bègles les
jeunes filles qui sont le coeur battant
15 16 ans qui veulent être aimés comme
elles étaient tous très connu et laisser
les enfants c'est aux parents de dire
aux enfants ça c'est bien ça c'est pas
bien ça c'est le spectacle mais ce n'est
pas la vraie vie des ducs et c'est pas à
l'état c'est pas l'éducation nationale
c'est tout
à l'heure c'était c'était les hommes
pardon prenez deux devant c'est pas vrai
vous regardez les grands duels de grands
noms de l'hôtellerie tc amélie neten
c'est nabila c'est chez bmc que des
filles qui ont explosé que c'est télé
réalité il n'ya pas du tennis en ce sens
et le sida amitié où les femmes sont
bien mieux payés en enfer si les hommes
et les femmes sont bien au-dessus métro
je vous confirme
vous parliez les jeunes filles qui font
30 kilos vous savez ce que c'est que
l'anorexie n'ont pas tous joué top model
qui sont sur des magazines mais
bien sûr voilà
discuter avec toutes mes influences leur
fait ou pas je vous assure que si vous
organisez une réunion avec les russes
elles viendront elles vous écouteront et
elles feront ce qu'il faut pour être
dans les temps mais c'est pas si c'est
un bête on attend que ça vous met les
enfants